Some of Boeing's 737 max.
Nine planes are grounded right
now, triggering cancellations nationwide.
FAA investigators want to make sure
that no other planes have the same flaw
potentially as an Alaska Airlines plane
that made an emergency landing Friday.
A portion of the plane's fuselage
blew off minutes
after takeoff,
sucking out some passengers belongings.
Nobody was seriously hurt,
but the NTSB admitted overnight
that they got lucky.
CNN's Mike Valerio
joins us now
from Portland, Oregon,
where the plane made
its emergency landing.
So what have we learned about this
new investigation?
Well, Victor and Amber,
good morning to you.
You know,
I think we got a pretty important window
into the thinking of the NTSB
when they stressed that
at this point of the investigation,
they are not, I repeat, not concerned
with the overall design
of the wider, larger max nine fleet.
They're looking at this specific plane.
And more to the point,
looking specifically for this
large hunk, the piece of the plane,
the door plug
that is still missing, Victor and Amara,
at this early Sunday morning hour.
So they narrowed their search
down, confirming noise yesterday
night to the Cedar Hills
community of Greater Portland
and told our viewers
know around the world
what we're talking about when we say
Cedar Hills, We're not describing
some idyllic,
uninterrupted section
of beautiful Oregon forest.
This is a suburban, dense community
close to the airport,
dozens of subdivisions,
hundreds of homes.
So the striking visual
that we're waiting for today
would be to look for FBI
agents and NTSB personnel
going door to door,
looking through people's backyards
for this piece.
The key
to the investigation of the plane.
So the NTSB chair, Jennifer Hamadeh,
made it also a specific point to say,
despite this accident,
how lucky the 171 people on board
were at the time this happened.
Listen to her on that front.
Those watching may be
curious about safety
or concerned about safety.
We have the safest
aviation system in the world.
It is incredibly safe.
We are the global gold
standard for safety around the world.
But we have to maintain that
standard.
And so what's going to happen
in the early morning hours,
the flight recorders will be sent
from Portland to NTSB headquarters
in Washington, D.C..
John Lovell takes over
as the chief investigator.
He has experience.
Victor Nomura,
representing the United States,
helping out Ethiopia in authorities
to investigate
the Max eight crash in 2019.
So he said these cases are
utterly different.
But every scene that he works
on adds to his perspect of,
as all of us
across the United States and around
the world are wondering,
what happened
to cause this plot emerging. Victor.
Yeah, exactly.
That is the question.
Mike Valerio, thank you very much.
Let's bring in former NTSB
air safety investigator
Alan Diehl to the conversation.
He's also the author of Air
Safety Investigators
Using Science to Save Lives
One Crash at a Time. Alan.
It's good to see you this morning.
First off, you know,
obviously people who fly
this is very unsettling.
And while the FAA has grounded
many of these, Max,
nine planes
with these replacement
plug doors or deactivated doors,
you know, what will they be looking for
in terms of safety checks
to make sure that these planes are
good to fly?
Well, they're going to
have to be very careful.
I believe the NTSB chair
or somebody mentioned
that this particular airplane
had a pressurization problem.
It's you know, it's
only 11 weeks old
at the time of the accident.
And if that I'm not suggesting
that this dark cloud
was the cause
of the pressurization problem,
but they'll be looking at that.
They'll look at
they'll interview the mechanics
that must have opened that door.
You open it from the outside.
You can open it from
the inside as a passenger.
But did they close it properly?
They'll also be looking
at the manufacturing
and the quality control
of this particular product.
So they're going to be busy.
As Mike pointed out,
they're also going to be obviously
looking for the missing door
that may be on somebody's roof.
Yeah, it's interesting to hear the NTSB
chair pleading, not pleading, but,
you know, making the case to the public
to be on the lookout for this panel.
Let's talk about the fuselage then,
because you mentioned
they're manufactured
by a subcontractor in Kansas.
How much oversight is there by Boeing
when when it's fuselages
are being manufactured on the max nine?
Well, the company is called
Spirit Aviation.
They used to be a division of Boeing,
but they spun it off for,
I guess for economic reasons.
But surely those are
the Boeing
people are familiar
with the assembly procedures
and the quality
they must have written
the quality control standards,
which had to be approved by the FAA.
Now, you've got to keep in mind
these plug
doors are not
particularly new to the 737.
I understand
they've been out there since 1996.
And whenever you have a problem
with a piece of component
or a piece of equipment
on an aircraft, you file a maintenance, a
a maintenance discrepancy report.
So they'll be looking at the history
of these plug doors also.
And before we go,
I got to ask you
about the history of the 737 max planes,
considering that, you know,
they've been involved in deadly crashes
and of course,
in recent weeks and days,
there were production issues
with these 737 max planes.
I mean, is there
should there be a broader concern
for some of these Boeing planes,
specifically the 737 max line?
Well, I.
Boeing has a long history
of engineering excellence,
and other people have pointed out
that they became
more commercial early again
in recent decades.
But because they only have one
competitor, Airbus.
And right now, Airbus is doing very well.
So the short answer is no.
But I do think their
continued scrutiny
needs to be maintained.
And we can talk about the relationship
of the FAA.
I work for the FAA as a scientist,
as you may have mentioned,
as well as an NTSB investigator.
But the up there,
the Boeing needs to be watched
and the FAA needs the resources
to do that.
Alan Dale, we'll leave it there.
Thank you very much.